i welcome those people who have just
joined we'll start within more five
minutes
i've started the live streaming on
youtube so if
and anyone misses out on the session due
to some internet connectivity they can
watch it on youtube as well
hello everyone welcome to the webinar we
will be starting in a few minutes
please put your questions in the chat
box and i request you all to please keep
your mind neutered
thank you
hello everyone i welcome you all to this
free webinar on omics logic summer
research
fellowship today we have a few speakers
who will be sharing about the data
science in biology
and the research fellowship
opportunities we hope that this will
help some of you see a path for yourself
and ask any questions you might have to
learn more about the fellowship and omix
logic resources in the chat box
so let's start with the introduction
about us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who are working with the multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
we are doing this by providing training
and tools that help people make
discoveries
using next generation sequencing and
other types of high throughput data
we see this as a result of accelerated
pace of biological data generation and
availability
of next generation sequencing
technologies throughout the different
locations in the world and
widespread appreciation of the accuracy
and details that such
data can provide us my name is sunalika
ray
and i am the omixlogic community manager
i am responsible for daily interaction
with thousands of users that are a part
of a bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech
omix logic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between
pine biotech and an innovative big data
analytics company based in the us
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been
thoroughly tested around the world and
are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science and
biomedical research
i'm honored to have been working with a
team that collectively has an amazing
experience in this
area including the other co-founders of
the company
dr alfred tauber who comes from a
medical background with expertise in
oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information
he has a long-standing recognition for
his generous support of many
international projects
and research activities one of these
projects is the establishment of the
global bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brodsky is the director of
the tribal bioinformatics research
center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career
he has developed multiple novel
algorithmic approaches to biomedical
data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research
in biotechnology pharmaceutical r d
agriculture and basic research what we
will discuss
today and throughout this program is a
result of hard work
by some of the people mentioned here on
the left
julia panna who was an expert by
information and helped prepare many of
the materials we will use
avitavsky who is a computer scientist
and leads
the the development of tbio info
platform
that we will use to carry out our
research project
and i will also be introducing our team
members in india in the next few slides
omixlogic is an international program
that is running
in five different regions with over ten
thousand users around the world
due to the fast growth our team is
working with local
and regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program logistics
and leverage our online training program
resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
omics logic program follows a project
based learning approach
using research grade tools to analyze
data from
top peer reviewed journals omixlogic
training has been completed by over 10
000 participants from 162 countries
in over 300 workshops for six different
specialization
tracks bm being oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data
and comprehensive training on omics data
analysis
now let me introduce you to our
omixlogic team
first we have the co-founder and ceo of
the company ilia brodsky
and then our bioinformatics trainers
clinton kuna and dr harpreet kaur
and dr mohit mazumdar who is our
partnership and project mentor
dr harpreet kaur is a bioinformatics
expert
and she has over 18 international
peer-reviewed research papers
in journals with impact factor 120 her
citation edge indexes
8. she has conducted over 15
bioinformatics and data science training
programs
in india africa and usa he looks after
our education curriculum development and
bioinformatics and data science course
development
as well let me introduce dr mohit
mazumdar who has an experienced
bioinformatician
with multiple publications in
peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
over the past several years he has been
developing collaborations with
universities as a mentor
and project lead for omics logic
training and research
fellowship he has over 13 international
peer-reviewed research papers in
journals with impact factor 120
his citation edge index stands seven he
has
five books chapter and five novel
bioinformatics tools and algorithms
as well and he specialized in
computational structured biology
atomistic molecular modeling and
simulations
now i would like to introduce our ceo
ilia brodsky
he has a background in bioinformatics
data science project management and
commercial product development
he currently serves as a ceo of pine
biotech which is a company that develops
and commercializes data analysis
software
solutions for life sciences since 2014
providing commercial and research
support using the big data g bioinfo
multi omics integration platform
mr brosky has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers
at stanford ucsf lauisana state
university tulane
and other academic and pharma r d teams
ilya brodsky will be overseeing the
project and managing the development of
the prototype preparation of the
relevant data projects
and implementation of the system for the
needs of students and teachers that the
project is designed for
now i would like to hand it over to elia
brodsky to discuss
more about the program over to you india
thank you okay thank you very much
and welcome everyone to this webinar
um i hope that everyone found
all of the details necessary for today's
session
and what i will do in my part of the
presentation is speak a little bit about
why we are doing what we are doing then
what is the research
fellowship program all about and how you
will be able to benefit
from different resources that we have
prepared for this program
and how you can gain access to the
resources that we will discuss
so again uh thank you so much for uh
the introduction i'll briefly go over
some of the similar things that
someoneika already mentioned but i want
to specify
why we are doing what we are doing first
and talk about
how the team members that we have in our
team
will be able to help you develop
research projects over the summer
so the background of our company is that
we started as the technology transfer
company started from this bioinformatics
research center
that is focused on developing of novel
algorithms to process and integrate
multi-omics data
and so what our team does is leverages
the same tools
and develops training resources to
support research projects
and apply the different methods that are
being developed at the center
as well as the other methods that are
being tested
and benchmarked to a variety of
different biomedical research projects
and one of our main goals as a company
is to democratize bioinformatics and so
we've been working with
many different companies universities
organizations
and non-profit organizations as well as
for-profit organizations
and the goal is really to make
bioinformatics more accessible because
what we have discovered is that
many students as well as faculty and
researchers coming from a
life science background do not have
enough resources and training to
translate
research questions into data science
problem statements
and into a bioinformatics workflow and
so what we've been doing
with a number of these partners is
developing examples
and case studies around different types
of data
and different types of challenges that
arise with that data
so that students and faculty can
effectively address those
using bioinformatics tools and so that's
how this onyx logic bioinformatics
training curriculum was born
we essentially developed it addressing
this need
of growing amounts of data and
limited opportunities for people around
the world to be able to easily access
that data using relevant tools and so we
developed the
regional offices with an office in india
that
serves many different universities there
starting in january 2019 we've conducted
many different online and
in-person workshops and programs
we also recently established a
an office in africa where we have a
regional
team based out of nigeria so
i see many of you here have joined us
from
africa so welcome to all of you as well
um
there we are growing the impact of the
program by
offering these programs together with
our collaborators and
analyzing the data to be addressing
the different types of needs that are
unique to this region
and developing projects that are
relevant to
people in africa as well and of course
in
the u.s we have the privilege of working
with a number of
partners uh including one of our main
collaborations with the louisiana
biomedical research network
as well as georgetown university where
we have
programs for students that apply for
biomedical research projects and for
medical
studies as well and so as a result of
these collaborations
we've seen a number of students
and faculty work together on impactful
and translational projects and so we're
excited
to bring this opportunity to you all
online as well
and so what we are doing with this
curriculum and with support elements
that i will discuss here briefly
we are trying to enable teams of
students and independent students to
develop
impactful and competitive research
projects leveraging
big data sets mentorships and
expert feedback so that those projects
are more competitive
and so the way that this process starts
is really
from training and so before we jump into
the research part
of this program i want to briefly
mention what this training is all about
uh so nanika do we have the poll ready
uh yes india we have it ready okay
so before we go on i wanted to make sure
that we
know who is present in this uh
session today and so uh we told you a
little bit about
our team uh so nika please launch the
poll um
if you could please take a few moments
of your time
and answer some of these questions that
will be popping up on the screen in just
a second
okay so um okay can we launch the poll
so my first question is what is your
educational background please let us
understand
uh from which educational background you
are and then my second question is what
are your research
in trust it would be great if we could
let if we could know what your research
interests are
either it is oncology omics data science
biomedical science machine
learning virology r and python
programming angry bioinformatics
precision medicine or neuroscience
you can take a minute i will be ending
the poll in the minute
thank you
okay so um can everybody
see the poll
okay great
all right perfect so if you could please
answer those uh
questions we'll just give another minute
for everybody to be able to answer
and so what we're looking for is to
really get to know you
and understand better what are
your interests what is your background
and also try to adapt this program to
the needs
of those that are present today we also
have this webinar
available as a recording after the
session is over
so for everyone that is uh watching this
on youtube
uh i think it's uh streaming live there
as well
uh we don't have a poll available on
youtube but you can definitely answer
your questions
in the chat we're monitoring the chat
and so we'll be collecting your feedback
there as well
okay let's give it just another 30
seconds
and uh maybe sonorica you can let me
know when
people have completed that
okay sure again
thank you all for your responses uh
those who are left
please sell in the responses thank you
okay so again thank you for the
responses maybe we can keep it on just
for a few more seconds but um let me
tell you briefly
what is the objective
of the first stage of this program so as
was mentioned
we're talking here about the research
fellowship we'll get to the research
part
later but first let me explain how the
basic training works
so we have a an online portal
that is called onyx logic so you can all
take a look at the pla at the portal
right now it's uh
learn.omicslogic.com
and what this portal offers
is a series of
course work okay so that's the link
on the basics of bioinformatics so
anyone
that is present here today that just has
some basic
understanding of bioinformatics or even
with very limited understanding of
bioinformatics what it is and how it
applies to different biomedical research
challenges we offer a basic introduction
to bioinformatics we
have different omics specific types of
training like genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics and then there is an
extensive curriculum on data science
that includes
data exploration data analysis
visualization
and machine learning so please explore
the different courses
uh again in sonoma maybe you could post
a few links there so people can take a
look
now on top of this asynchronous type
of coursework we also offer
an in-depth and expert guided
training and so as an example we have
these programs
that are called omixlogic
transcriptomics
omixlogic data science so we have a
number of programs that are designed
around the specific challenges
associated with these types of data
as well as specialization tracks and
those specialization tracks include
oncology infectious diseases
agriculture and others and so as a
result
this portal offers a complete roadmap
for
bioinformatics and we go from finding
data sets
to knowing how to explore and visualize
the data to understand the problem
statement and what they represent
to read through research articles and
understand the research methods
as well as to gain biological and
translational insights and
understanding of what is the impact of
this particular
method study data set and so that type
of training
really introduces you into a
bioinformatics roadmap
from where you can then choose to
specialize in
specific domains so the onyx logic
bioinformatics training
is a topics and specialized program for
different types of research challenges
and those
include challenges and infectious
diseases like
coven challenges in genomic medicine
like personalized treatment of cancer
metagenomics how to explore the
microbiome and the impact of microbiome
on
different aspects of uh in of
disease and health precision oncology
data science and neuroscience so to
really explain how this works
i want to just briefly show you what
kinds
of materials you will gain access by
joining this program and also by just
registering for free even if you're not
registered
for the research fellowship or one of
these programs i just want to make sure
that you understand how these resource
resources could be used so they include
training materials that you can learn
from
data analysis tools that include big
data analysis tools because not always
can you
analyze data on your laptop you really
need this infrastructure to support your
big data analysis needs
training in coding where you can try
different types of r packages and python
as well as an introduction to different
project data sets
so you can really explore a variety of
case studies of how this applies
so let's take a look i'm going to go to
to the browser and please join me
as well so
learn on mixlogic.com
and please do let me know if you're
already registered
maybe you could put yes or no
in the chat box if you're registered all
right
excellent thank you so as you're on this
uh home screen if you're already in the
system you will see your email address
come up right here
so for those of you that are not yet
registered this is free registration so
really
no obligation this is just to explore
but you can see here
how some of these resources are
organized
and they are specific to different types
of
uh applications oncology infectious
diseases neuroscience agriculture
and what's important is that they offer
once you register
once you've created that first
registration you
automatically get access to our big data
analysis platform
now this big data analysis platform is a
complete separate
beast so to say right it's got a lot of
resources that you can leverage
which are explained in some of the
coursework that you can gain access to
so let's take a look at what this big
data analysis platform
allows us to do now you will if you're
registered
on the learn portal you can use the same
registration
to see what this big data analysis
platform is all about because you will
have a demo
account okay so this is the link
to this platform it is server.tbio.info
okay please let me know once you're here
okay so again login use the same login
same email and password that you created
there
you should be able to register here and
we'll take a look at just one example
so here we have different types of
honest data
types next generation sequencing data
mass spec
structural biology as well as data
integration and modeling
so some of you might be already familiar
with this right one of the biggest
challenges that
so many data sets are available but they
contain thousands of samples
gigabytes of data you have to download
them on your computer
most of the time you can't even do
anything with them because they just
require
terabytes of space and so this is a
cloud-based platform that allows you to
eliminate that challenge you can just
simply go online
upload your data directly from ncbi or
from an ftp link
and process that data and so that's one
of the amazing things that are
available on this platform so let's take
a look at one example
here we have a demo of how this
platform works so you first of all start
by selecting one of the demos
you have a brief explanation of
what the basic steps are so this is the
logic
behind this type of omics data
processing
you can see that you do pre-processing
mapping on the reference genome
and then quantification of expression
levels so how many of you here are
familiar with rna-seq
is anyone here familiar okay so i see
connect valley
okay lee all right great so
all right great so you will probably
already recognize
many of the steps that are mentioned
here
and what you can do is not worry about
the organization of these steps in a
logical workflow because the system is
guided by artificial intelligence to
suggest the right type of next step
based on the data type and your
objective
okay so if you are just coming from a
theoretical background you kind of know
what is going on but you don't know how
practically it works
this is exactly what you can use so
remember the first step was
pre-processing so we'll select
trumatic which is designed to trim the
reeds
and clean up our source data then we can
eliminate the bridge amplification
because sequencing includes pcr
amplification that is a little bit
biased towards
some sequences and higher expressed
genes then we can choose between
a number of different methods for
mapping on the full genome
or the transcriptome so we'll just
choose a quicker version
mapping on the transcriptome and then
preparing that table of expression that
we will be able to use
downstream analysis tools to annotate
explore analyze and ultimately interpret
so
here we have the rsm expression table
once we have built our pipeline just
click on end
and now you can see the output data and
so
very quickly you can go from
understanding the project
to then being able to explore the data
that is already processed and so now
this data is something that you can
download onto your computer
or even better i will show you how you
can process it
using some of the data exploration tools
that we have
on the onyx onyx logic learn
platform okay so let's go back to
the learn portal
and i'll show you the next example so
here we built our
table of expression right so in the
table of expression
we prepared a full table of
gene expression for something like tens
of samples
okay so here if you can search
r and we're going to go into this
introduction to data science in r okay
because the next step after you've
prepared your data
now you can load the data visualize it
perform different types of statistical
analysis
explore your data with dimensionality
reduction
perform differential gene expression and
use all kinds of downstream methods so
here i'll just show you a brief example
of how this would work
again this is for those that created a
free account you should be able to
access
most of these courses and what we'll do
is we'll go right here
into dimensionality reduction because
one of the
bigger challenges is that we have so
many dimensions
so here you can see we've got our genes
they have expression levels
we have samples right and then each
sample belongs to different
type of data so this is taken from a
breast cancer
example project and as you complete the
introduction
you then have this video that explains
what the code is all about
explains the syntax of the code so you
understand how you load the data
and prepare your principal component
analysis
object which later on you can visualize
because
r is a object-oriented
object-oriented language and then how
can you improve your visualization using
that object
so that you understand the biological
meaning behind the complexity of this
gene expression data set
now importantly you can actually
practice this
right here in the browser so again you
have this explanation
but you also have these uh blocks
of code okay and this code
actually comes with a challenge okay so
for example you can't just run this code
but you can go to a basic plot right so
here i'm going to just run the code
that's already available
okay and i get some basic outputs
so the basic outputs include some basic
plots
but once i want to start changing them
you can see that
i have to modify the code for it to work
okay why the reason is because i need to
start
reading through the syntax and
identifying
the specific types of steps that i need
to
make so that this code works so let's
briefly
do this together you can see right table
i have it right here i need to create a
table so i'm just going to copy this
from right here
and i have
making the plot from the previous step
so how do we actually make the plot
from the previous step okay right here
we need to make the plot from the
previous step so by
looking through the code and
understanding the code
i can actually make this code work okay
what didn't work here to make sure that
all the syntax
is true this
okay i don't have
input file okay
okay and so now i made this code work
i have this code right here and i have
created
a table of expression okay and so
now i can analyze the table of
expression in a transform format so i
know what it means
okay so because this
process is something that we've tested
on thousands of users
we have developed a whole system that
goes from this
kind of basic training all the way
into a project that you can now
analyze in the context of a biological
problem and so these include examples
from taken from literature where we
actually go through
examples in research papers with the
associated data set
and you can find different examples on
ebola
on covet 19 on precision medicine in
oncology
and many other different types of
examples so in
every case you will get an introduction
based on some kind of a data set that is
explained
in a publication you get different types
of methods being explained and then some
challenges that you can try and go
through
by yourself now in many cases we try to
break down
every step so that it's very clear what
the logic is behind the analysis
and not get bogged down by the technical
details
so eliminating the need for
comprehensive technical training before
you can actually
start a project of your own and so
what's important is that
we have this platform that allows big
data processing
different types of statistical methods
regression and factor analysis
machine learning multi-omics integration
and biological interpretation
as a result as we mentioned now
we are going to talk about this
fellowship so
who is the fellowship for the fellowship
is for those that have completed the
basic training
they already understand how
bioinformatics is used
and now they can apply what they have
learned
to a project of their own so how many of
you here
have come to this webinar to learn about
how to join the research fellowship
all right great okay
so the research fellowship is
specifically
for those that are going to be able to
leverage some of the examples data sets
learn about different challenges that
are
presented in these projects these
challenges are going to be associated
with different
domains as we already described and you
can see some of the examples on the
screen that we have already prepared
and once you are ready and you have
selected a topic
you can now apply the same principles
to a project of your own
and so you can either join the training
and i will pass it on to dr mohit
mizunder after my
part of the presentation so that he can
explain what kinds of programs are going
to be coming up that you can gain
access to expert guided training to
asynchronous coursework
and the research support that we offer
but for those of you that are done with
your training
and have already completed your basic
training
now you can go for an independent
project and so that's where this
omixlogic research fellowship comes in
so let me briefly tell you what is
the research fellowship and how does it
actually work
so the research fellowship is organized
into
three different parts first we have an
introduction
so that you can review and refresh
your understanding of uh different types
of bioinformatics methods
but it's going to be brief the important
thing is that as a part of this program
you will gain access to a variety of
programs that we have
going on during the summer so that you
can get that training
next there's a process of evaluating
the proposal the project proposal i'll
talk about how
challenging and how to address that
challenge of selecting a good topic and
finding a good data set
so during that time once you have
the evaluation step you're really
working on developing a research
proposal
to also understand the experimental
design of how the data
was prepared and the making sure that
the question that you have
is actually competitive
and important and significant and you
will
end up with an impactful project at the
end right so it's
refinement of that research question
that you have
and then you have also practical aspects
so then you actually conduct
the different research analysis methods
you apply them to your data you find the
insights through
identifying specific patterns in the
data and then you have to go for
biological interpretation
so in this process
you will have weekly progress reports
that you have to submit
to your mentor you have a slack channel
where you can
interact with the mentor experts as well
as
additional people that are going to be
present okay and those of you that
feel that you need training we will talk
about training here in a few minutes
but for the research fellowship once you
join we will actually go through this
process with a weekly review and
uh you will hear today from some of our
research fellows on how they went
through this process as well
so the first step obviously is to
collect data right
and so we will introduce you to
different data sources where you can
find
uh big data on almost any topic so
many of you are probably familiar with
ncbi ncbi
has millions of data sets that you can
find
on a huge variety of topics and so for
example
uh many research data sets are available
on source code too
right literally every paper that comes
out has an associated data set
that anyone can go in and explore
and so what we just did with that pca
for cell lines
you can just take a data set from geo
download it
or even directly use it from ncbi and
see some patterns for example here
we have some pattern of separation based
on gene expression between
h2 overexpression in patients with
asthma
and with covet 19 so you can see the
difference
between those two conditions and so the
obvious
challenge when you are faced with
millions of data sets that you could
potentially
access is how to choose that specific
topic for your project
and so here we will provide you with
some training
so that you understand how to select an
impactful topic
how to select a topic that is reasonable
and also how to make sure that that
topic has
significant data that you can analyze
during your research fellowship
then you will go through a process of
literature reviews
you will get to review articles that are
either primary research articles review
articles systematic review articles
and you'll get to explore different
types of problem statements
questions and data sets that experts
have
already gone through and the important
part is that you will be able to define
from a very general problem statement
like i want to apply
my bioinformatics skills to infectious
diseases
to select a very specific hypothesis or
a question
based on your literature review
identifying gaps and unanswered
questions
and then defining your own question and
hypothesis so as a result you will
end up with a very competitive project
proposal
that you can actually start working on
and so then you will develop
comprehensions
comprehension and analysis skills by
going through these research articles
understanding the methodology
you will be able to investigate the
problem
in depth and understand what challenges
are there
and then we will go to actually writing
editing and preparing
the project for submission and so what
we've done on our side and you will
see this from some of our research
fellows that will present today
how this step-by-step process
actually enables you to come out with a
project that leverages big data applies
advanced and sophisticated methods
and then comes out as a research study
that you can present and share with
others
so once your data set is ready and you
define your question you will
process your data and so as i showed you
there's this training that will allow
you to leverage these
big data analysis tools and identify
signal you will be able to leverage
uh different types of scripting methods
and analysis methods to define what that
pattern is that you want to focus on
perform in-depth analysis in a variety
of applications
from gene expression data to drug
resistance and structural biology data
population genetics and others
biological interpretation like pathway
analysis and others
and then start working on completing
that project and so
what could be the outcome of the
research fellowship
so first of all we follow the same
process that you would follow
if you were preparing a research poster
presentation so
as you probably know many students start
with
a research poster to develop their
project
and get some feedback and so this
program
the research fellowship will provide you
with these guaranteed
outcomes that depending on the effort
that you put in and the timing that you
have
you will be able to achieve and so some
of these could be
just understanding the challenges
associated with bioinformatics so if
you're a student
and you want to understand whether this
is for you
you might want to go through some of the
coursework
understand the challenges complete some
of the projects that we offer
and that will give you a clear
perspective on whether bioinformatics is
for you
or how could you use it in your domain
another outcome
is that you will get training and
develop those skills and so once you've
tried it on one project
you can then continue working on other
projects and apply the same skills and
the training that you've gotten
so that you can actually understand how
this is
applied in a variety of different areas
then you can work on an independent
or a group research project and so
that's where this
three-month or six-month training
converts into a research fellowship
that you can actually work on a project
either independently or we can match you
with some
similar people that could be interested
in working together
okay so you will fill out your profile
we'll see how you do in training you'll
submit some of the
research progress that you're making and
then we'll be able to pair you with some
others
and then finally what we definitely see
majority of the people
going for is to complete a poster
presentation
or develop a full uh full research
publication
so at this point i want to invite a
couple of our
research fellows that are going to share
just a few words
about their experience in the research
fellowship so that you can see
what they went through and how this
process developed for them
so sonalika if you could please make
sure that they are ready
to share their slides
and um as we're waiting for them to uh
share this um i want to ask and address
some of the questions that are in the
chat
okay so um let's go through these
questions and somebody could please let
me know when
the next research fellow is ready
okay so is it possible to go for three
or six months yes we will address the
questions of registration just a little
bit
what is the pricing we will go through
the pricing again in a little bit we
also have some
uh we also have so so there's not really
a price to the research project itself
there's a whole program that you can
register for and that
gives you access to the mentorship gives
you the access to the
experts that will provide you with
feedback on your project and also gives
you access to the training
and the big data analysis tools okay
so uh just so that everybody can see
how to actually register i'm going to
just
share a link here real quick so if you
go
to the top right here and you click on
research
okay right here this is where you
complete
the registration okay so if you're
interested
in the fellowship program this is where
you go
this is where you complete the
registration if you have questions about
pricing this is the pricing you can
switch between three and six months
and then you'll be able to choose which
option is best for you
if you're interested in a scholarship
and you come from
a low-income country or you have a
special
need there's also a scholarship
process that we have that you can use to
apply for a scholarship
we only will give a number of
scholarships so the earlier you apply
the better uh mohit and
sonic are you here yes india so i would
like to invite dr
anita first to share uh her naguchi
research
program and then might be we can start
with our research fellows would that
work
yes that would be great but could you
please put the links here
um people are asking in the chat so yeah
let's go with anita
and please address some of those
questions in the chat thank you
over to you dr anita
okay so i think uh she's not audible
right now so supanta can you please oh
you just need to
you just need to unmute her uh sonalika
she can't unmute herself you need to
give her the permission to
unmute so you go to her profile
you're the host so you have to do it
okay
so um thank you good good afternoon
good morning wherever you find yourself
my name is anita ganza
and i work at the noguchi memorial
institute for medical research
in ghana and i don't have any slides to
give you but just to share with you
what we've been doing with the pine bio
program the past six months to
um in terms of research
training in bioinformatics for
infectious
diseases um
so noguchi memorial institute
it's a biomedical research center in
ghana it's part of the university of
ghana
and one of our key mandates is to
conduct by medical research to inform
public health policies so
malaria as you know is very important
it's a very important public health
concern in sub-saharan africa
and that is my core area of
research so as a team
we approach the pine group
what we normally do is to
look at resistance to malaria parasites
why these malaria parasites become
resistant to the anti-malarial drugs
that
our malaria control programs administer
and we advise these policy makers
on the circulating malaria parasites and
why the drugs are not working and they
need to change
drugs not only do we look at drug
resistance we are also interested in
interventions like vaccines
so if for instance a vaccine is being
introduced
we are interested in looking at the
effect of
these vaccines on the circulating
malaria
population in order to see
why this vaccine is not so efficacious
why is it more efficacious in this
region compared to other regions
and we are also interested in
understanding the mechanisms
underlining either resistance or the
efficacy of a
vaccine and so
this is something we've been doing for a
while now we approached pine group to
support us to um strengthen our
bioinformatics
still with the objective of informing
the public health policies as we've been
doing
so for drug resistance
we are looking at two drugs or three
drugs
the sulfadoxane perimeterman which
is a synergistic drug
that is used for um
prevention of malaria in pregnant women
and in children living in
um seasonal malaria
regions in sub-saharan africa so the
idea is to give it
to these people to prevent malaria or
for the children
so that when the transmission peak is
due
they would have had some drugs and
it will reduce their um
parasite load so we are interested in
genes that are involved in resistance to
this um drug
with pines we've not just looked at the
mutations
in these genes that are involved in
resistance
what we've done is to look at the effect
of these
um circulating mutations or variants
in the ghanaian population and in other
african populations to see
the effect of the variant on the protein
structure
or the active sites of the proteins
to understand why resistance is ongoing
we are also tracking these mutations
in regions outside
ghana other african countries to see
whether
the emerging resistance patterns that we
are observing in ghana
are also being replicated elsewhere
or whether some of the resistant
patterns we are observing in ghana
are just localized
patterns that we are seeing and again
the
impact on the proteins themselves
now the second drug that we are
interested in is chloroquine
chloroquine as you know it's no longer
used in sub-saharan africa to a larger
sense
however we are tracking
the re-expansion
of chloroquine-sensitive parasites so
it was topped because the parasites had
developed so much resistance
to this drug that there was no need
using it
but when we left this intervention for a
while
we see that there is the re-expansion of
the sensitive parasites
and this is very important for us to
track one
to see how chloroquine can be reused
either as a single dose for
prevention of malaria or in combination
with other drugs
now the second reason why we are
interested in chloroquine is that
um some of the currently
being used drugs currently we are using
artemisinin
in combination with other drugs like
amuda queen
and lumifantrine
now the re-imagined
chloroquine sensitive parat parasites
may also cause
resistance to these partner drugs so
it's important to
monitor mutations in these genes that
are involved in chloroquine
resistance not only to track the
re-expansion of chloroquine-sensitive
parasites but also
to see the effect of these
sensitive parasites on the drugs that we
are currently
using and again with pine we are not
stopping
at looking at the existence of these
mutations in our ghanaian population
but we are also interested in
how these mutations are affecting the
active site of the proteins
and trying to understand exactly the
mechanism of resistance how resistance
actually
works because yes chloroquine we have
some ideas but we still do not
understand exactly how
chloroquine works and how resistance
comes about
because it is more heterogeneous than
you may think of it so we are trying to
understand
how the variant circulating in the
ghanian population
are affecting the structure of the
protein
and if we find that there are important
variants
either acting in synergy with a known
chloroquine resistant mutations in order
to cause resistance
then our next step is to see exactly how
this
is happening through modeling
or molecular dynamics to understand
exactly the interaction or the effect of
these variants
on the protein now
in terms of um vaccines
we are interested in candidates that are
being developed
for malaria vaccine for the second
sporozoid
protein of the malaria parasite it's the
only
vaccine that has been developed to
the stage where it's been approved and
it's currently
being um introduced
on a pilot scale in a phase 4 trial
in four african three african countries
including ghana
malawi and kenya now
our interest as you may know
is that this
vaccine even though has been approved
was only
about 30 to 50 percent efficacious
in certain groups of children 5 months
to 17 years old
so we are interested in understanding
why
we are not getting an efficacious
malaria vaccine
yes recently just last month one malaria
vaccine
was um tested at the phase 2 level and
we got about 70
efficacy but what has been approved
which is the
rtss vaccine developed from the
circumstance protein
was only as good as 30 percent so
we are interested in understanding why
the vaccine hasn't been efficacious
we've done this by looking at the
diversity
of the vaccine antigen that is the csp
the second sporozoid protein
across ghana and we can see that
the epitope or the
gene is so diverse in ghana
and there is within region
diversity and there is no way such a
vaccine
will give us even the 30 percent
efficacy that we are expecting we are
not expecting to see the same in
different regions of ghana we are also
interested in
looking at how these circulating
variants again affect the function
of the antigen how it is affecting the
t cell epitopes and
the reason why the vaccine is not
efficacious
and lately with covert 19
we've also developed interest in
understanding why
we seem to have less mortality
in sub-saharan africa and even
the severity of covet 19
is not as severe as in the western world
comparing the cases to
sub-saharan africa and in ghana
particularly so with pine we are
developing
a program or what we call the covered
malaria
initiative to understand what is
happening we have hypothesized that
repeated infections with malaria
parasites
might have sustained our immune system
such that people are able to handle
covet
even though you may be infected with a
virus
virus you're able to handle it better
than people living in the western world
we are aware of um factors such as
the age grouping for
um death from covet in the western world
we know that
our um
we tend to have a younger population in
sub-saharan africa
we are aware of environmental or
socio-economic factors
that may influence covet 19
disease but we think
that immune responses to malaria might
have contributed
so we are looking at
um differences in gene expression
profiles in people with mild
and severe covered um cover 19
in relation to people who are partially
immune as a result of repeated
infections
from malaria parasites to understand
which genes
are more highly expressed
in order to understand why um covet 19
mortality is less in sub-saharan africa
we're also interested in looking at um
the differences in cytokine responses
between um people who
are partially immune as a result of
repeated malaria infections compared to
covered 19
cases and also we are interested
in immune response cells that are
involved in these two diseases all
in a bit to understand um
why covet 19 mortality is much higher
in um the western world compared to
sub-saharan africa we as a group
have tabbed on in the um
genomics studies that prime biotech has
conducted and we are also looking at the
transcriptomics
to undertake these projects and it's
been a very very
good experience and i would encourage a
lot of you to partake especially
in this program so thank you very much
thank you and i just want to also
mention
that um anita and her group um
are from the meguchi memorial uh
institute for medical research
um and uh if anyone from
ghana is uh interested to understand how
exactly this worked
uh for her group and her students i'm
sure that
um you can reach out to us and we will
connect you with her
we also have a team in nigeria and
adekunle who is managing that team
is present here so if you have any
questions you can also reach out to him
they have special training available in
nigeria coming up soon
but tsunamika again thank you anita for
uh sharing
i think those are very exciting projects
and we're looking forward to seeing
the results uh and uh also i wanted to
ask
if you could now pass it on to the
research fellows to share
from their experience thank you so much
india yes now i would like to welcome
supanthade
who is our research fellow and he would
be talking about his experience with
fine
and would also be telling us about his
uh project
over to yusupanda thank you
yes hello sorry
just a second
so i guess everyone can see me
so uh this is me shubham today uh
student of genetic engineering and
biotechnology at university of turkey
so i have currently been in a research
fellowship program in comics logic
bioinformatics
doctor happ madam has been my supervisor
so today i am going to discuss my
journey and how mentors and this
internship
helped me to gain knowledge and idea
about developing a project and what i
did
so what did i do actually well
first of all all courses and projects
yeah
i or you were going to do this research
fellowship
will gain access to after enrolling well
they will guide you and they have
they will be super helpful and they will
be fun
i remember for the first time i didn't
feel bored when i studied and went
through these courses all day
the the knowledge you gain from these
courses and projects
will help you to do works for the
research project later on
and also these projects will uh guide
you in various courses
as uh dr already said like in
transcriptomics or genomics and
in any and you can also do the projects
you will feel interested into
also apart from using bioinformatics
tools i was also
exposed to the world of programming of
data science and bioinformatics
it was a nice experience when you
realize you can visualize your data set
with r and you can do lots of analysis
one thing that is not mentioned anywhere
today that is
you will know some cool people and make
friends around when you do this project
for example i did make some good friends
uh where
undergraduate as me i came to know
people who are senior researchers or
pursuing phd
it is very helpful when you get this
exposure
i think i talked enough about what why i
love it here
i'll give you a short summary of my work
so this is the research question i
choose
so this is the one how the third dose of
malaria says s1 vaccine is associated
with controlled information
and increased protection so before going
further
uh i want to tell you how i came to this
research question well when i choose a
research program first
it was you know it was vast and not
specific i remember my mentors helped me
to be specific and they guided me like
you have to choose a good data set they
have to
they have to be properly utilized and
also the problem
that has to be unique and noble the
first time i choose a problem that was a
novel and the data set was so small
and you know they will guide you through
all the processes
okay so i wanted to mention that
also four or five months ago i didn't
know much about bioinformatics analysis
or how to deal with dataset or how to
interpret result or how to do multiple
type of comics
analysis so here in the internship you
will learn all of those
from the courses and projects and not to
mention the
mentors will guide you whenever you are
stuck or you do a mistake
so i want to tell you why i choose
malaria because i
guess anita just before me she explained
everything why it is
still a crucial problem and it is taking
lots of lives
those of us who live in asia or in
europe
we do not understand that but you know
in africa it is affecting very badly
so i'll now show you some of the
analysis that we
did and i will not go into the technical
details at this
in this slide you can find out that uh
after differential gene
expression analysis uh in either we
found 219 genes are significantly
expressed
while we compare between pre-vaccination
step and the day of challenge day of
challenge is
uh was three weeks after the vaccination
where you know controlled human malaria
infection was
applied also you can see the threshold
for
uh our result also here
you can see it is a volcano plot for all
the chains
we use pc to uh achieve this and
this is the heat map i also want to
mention that you can all
do it in the platform that will show you
before on and also you can do
it by yourself in the r if you go
through the courses
also this pc plot here for example let
us see
why this is important so you can see
these samples they are there
the below one the j40 samples they are
you know different from other groups
they're
not together also one and they're
treated these two
uh i guess you can see sorry here yeah
day one and day three samples they are
together
from other groups and you know the day
of challenge here
they are here so we can
interpret many things for example
in our study we found out that cytokine
related genes were
significantly expressed so
conclusion over expression of cytokines
is associated with you know uh
driving forces of death in malaria
related diseases so
uh here we try to find out how
those genes which are significantly
expressed uh affect the pathways and uh
we did in return as you can see and in
the platform we did the human gait
analysis here we we can see the
significant genes
uh in our analysis they are involved in
cytokine related pathway
so we came to this conclusion how
malaria vaccination helps to down
regulated those
genes the cytokine neurons which which
would otherwise
you know increase the severity of
malaria and
increase the chance of death so we
visualized our data set and we analyzed
it and
uh and that is all so i i
i haven't gone into the details because
there is short time and
i think it would be best if i give you
an idea what they did
so that will be all uh
and i want to thank find biotech for
giving me this chance to present and
do this analysis and thank you everyone
thank you
thank you so much it was great hearing
from you
now i would like to invite uh saeed
our another research fellow to talk
about her uh
experience with us over to you saeeda
thank you
hello everyone um are you able to see my
screen
yes okay so um hi everyone my name is
i go by my middle name which is maham i
have a masters in molecular and cell
biology from quinnipiac university
connecticut usa
i have about four years of four and a
half years of work experience as a
research associate
from which about a year and a half i
spent at yale university school of
medicine new haven connecticut
in which i was working in a lab that was
studying acute pancreatitis in a mouse
model
i was responsible for extracting the
pancreas tissue
isolating the ester cells doing rna
isolation for the purpose of microarray
analysis rtpcr
enzyme assays i pretty much learned tons
there and then the lab moved
to another state and i got a job at a
biotech company called protein sciences
corporation
and that company is bought by sanofi now
so at the time when i joined the company
they were getting their fda approval for
their flu vaccine the first ever egg
free vaccine called flu box so i really
got to see how the fda approval works
i in particular was working with a group
that was using the company's recombinant
technology
um to take orders from other larger
companies to generate
purified proteins for them so i got to
work with a lot of virus
virus-like particles and we purify those
proteins for the purpose
of developing a vaccine so i
particularly developed
a method for protein purification for
those very particular
um virus-like particles and then we
scaled it up and then
the analysis of the purified viruses
pretty much i got to learn tons and
after my three years there i
had a baby i took maternity leave
thinking i'm gonna go back
but i you know became a stay-at-home mom
i
was needed at home i felt more um i
loved being a mom but i definitely
missed
working in a research setup where we
collaborated with other people
and i wanted to do something from home
that's when i came across bioinformatics
i was familiar
with bioinformatics but i didn't realize
the scope
of bioinformatics in the future and how
i could do it remotely
and to learn more about bioinformatics i
did take advantage of courses from
edx and course era i even got a
micromasters from edx but i didn't
really feel
fulfilled because i know the way to
learn something is through
actually doing hands-on research and
that's when i came across
research fellowship at pine biotech
about a month and a half ago
and i joined them and i feel very
pleased so in this fellowship we do
start with
uh coursework like edx and coursera but
the highlight of pine biotech is that
you get to do
hands-on independent research project
now this gives you a chance to implement
what you have learned
from the coursework unlike other course
platforms where you just take the final
exam or
take end of end of you know course exam
here you actually get to do research
which i think
really helps with the implementation of
what you have learned
so this is the best aspect and another
thing is that most importantly you get
the opportunity to attend and present
at the weekly research meetings and get
the feedback from the mentors
um so even when you start their uh your
research fellowship and you don't really
know much about bioinformatics you
get to do the coursework and one of the
best things that
uh dr herpreek does is that she requires
that everybody
you know present what they have learned
each week and
do it in a powerpoint or whatever
presentation format
you choose and i think when you are
presenting that's when you get to learn
the most
and she dr harpreet is not a passive
listener she's an active listener and
she will cross question as you're
presenting
which i feel enforces at least me to be
on my a-game
and it really helps me learn and present
more effectively another thing is that
when you
are part of those weekly meetings you
get a sense of belonging to a scientific
community that you actually don't get
that feeling
if you're doing some courses
independently
and i think that is very very
fundamental in being able to learn and
progress
in a scientific field and this also
further aids in the learning curve so
when you get to hear
others present their research not only
are you learning about their
topic but i feel this also gives you um
you know a positive pressure to keep
working on your own research because
it's
um very common for people to actually
lag behind when we are doing
those you know open courseware on our
own and a lot of people end up giving up
but here because you have to tap in each
week
and show what you have learned it
enforces you to be on top of your
uh your material um or at least keep
going you know
keep making the progress so in the end i
would just like to say that based on my
previous work experience i feel that
pine biotech's research fellowship is
very well thought out the concept of lab
notebook to weekly meetings and the
opportunity to present
resembles real lab work experience
so i'm very grateful for that
opportunity and i would like to thank
pine bio for giving me the opportunity
to share my experience with all of you
and now over to sonalika thank you
thank you so much saeeda it was great
listening to your experience
and now i would be sharing my screen and
we have a lot of questions coming up
on the registration how to do it and the
pricing things as well
so first of all uh those who have not
signed up to our omixlogic learn portal
please you can go there and sign up and
there was one question in the chat box
that
can we take up one of the courses as the
sample courses before
taking any sort of training so yes you
can go to this uh
courses uh thing on the uh
on a portal and this courses column has
got all the courses enlisted here
and you can just simply sign up and take
up any course of your research interest
and that's that's the way we can move
ahead
so uh there are few courses which have
modules which are start modules
and to get the access to those
particular star modules
you need to take up the membership those
who are interested to take the
membership for the start modules they
can mail me at marketing at the rate
fine.bio and i'll explain it to them
about different sorts of memberships we
have and
then is our research fellowship
program blog so if you have any sort of
doubts regarding
uh the enrollment what would be covered
what would be the process
and you want to see and learn from our
research fellows project as well like
what they have done
so you can simply go go to this blog and
have a look
at all the details and also we have
the research project uploaded here by
our previous research fellow so you can
get an
idea of how do we work and what
quality of work is produced right
and uh yes so you can look out for the
registration as well here and what the
outcomes would be the time slots and
things
now if you talk about the uh
the registration and the proceedings so
we have this three months program and
then we have the six months program
and the costs for both the programs are
different
now i don't want people who are
researchers but they
uh can't afford this i really understand
that because of the situation the
situation has hit everyone badly and we
really understand and we don't want
it to affect our research and also we
really care for people who are very
passionate for research and that's why
we have this research scholarship
thing with us so you can simply go to
the research
scholarship page and register yourself
here
and while you register yourself here you
would have to submit a
research scholarship form where you have
to upload your cv
and answer a few questions we have asked
about you and also give us the
references of your
uh it could be a faculty uh and then we
can set up a meeting
and yes we would give good scholarships
to the researchers who are really
passionate for research
right and to register yourself for the
program
you have to go to the research
fellowship program page and register
yourself here
now there were many queries i got in the
mail that you were facing problem in
registering yourself
so people who face problem they can pro
like probably
load reload the page and then register
and try
still if the problem persists you can
anytime mail me and i'll be there to
help you out with that
also i wanted to tell you that you can
follow us on the social that is uh
on facebook we are by the name of pine
biodick so follow us there so that you
stay updated
with all the courses and trainings we
would be having
and on linkedin we are there by the name
of omixlogic machine learning biomedical
determining
uh page and also we are there by
omislogic
and find biotech and on instagram we are
there by
by informatics spine so we are there
everywhere on social so that you don't
miss an update about our upcoming
programs
and uh now i would uh like to
also answer one of the questions which
was there
what that what what all things would be
covered in the research fellowship
programs so a research fellowship
program is actually a power back
program where we would be giving the
access to all the courses and then we
have
monthly trainings in different sorts of
fields
like we have this training going on
right now it's on transfer comics
biomedical data science and drug
discovery
similarly we have many trainings every
month it
could be on data science machine
learning ngs
oncology precision medicine and the list
goes on right so you get to be a part of
those trainings as well
and the courses are there and also you
get to do your own research project
under the mentorship of our mentors dr
harpreet kaur and dr muhit mazumdar
and also our ceo india would help you
out with all the
projects and we have these weekly
meetings where we discuss
as our research fellows just shared
their experience and they told that we
have weekly meetings where we discuss
each and everything and whenever you
face any query in your research project
our mentors will be there to guide you
throughout the process
now i would like to pass it on to elia
to discuss
uh things further over to you yeah thank
you
uh thanks yeah actually it's to muhit so
mohit please over to you
hello everyone and thank you i hope that
you guys are not
uh bored already or falling asleep
so let me quickly share my screen and
show you the the programs that we
discussed so
how we are going to do it and uh what
are the upcoming opportunities so you
already know about me
so i would not be telling a lot about
myself here but
here i mean i am one of the specialists
in uh computational structural biology
and and
also ngs data so i've been able to work
on
several different bioinformatics
projects throughout my career
so that also includes association with
pharma
and uh academic career translational
projects so i've been working
on on for almost 12 years and have
all of that experience to help you with
your own project
so my here role is uh in pinela major
role
is to develop these partnerships with
collaborators
such as universities companies and also
like be a project mentor to
students who would need uh guidance to
you know go to the next step so about
that experience i think summer
this summer we have had an amazing
opportunity for all of you
to come interact with us and learn from
us a peer-reviewed panel so let me tell
you more about the uh
the upcoming programs and how there
could be a possibility to for you to
now work on your coursework like elia
like harpreet uh
sorry like sunalika india all of us have
been talking about that
start your basic training or start your
project right now
so that you can be uh you know future
ready and you can be also
uh utilizing the upcoming resources in
june and
especially in the month of june and july
so we have this
ongoing program with faba academy which
is a special wing under
organization that focuses on grooming of
students of university nationwide and
make them uh ready for industry and
academia
so to help with the awareness and to
contribute
this summer uh we are bringing this
unique opportunities for students and
researchers to join the research
fellowship program
and get feedback from an elite team of
industry and academy experts and mentors
to learn and apply data-driven research
for drug discovery
so let me just quickly introduce you
some of these
researchers and scientists and mentors
and ceos
who would be helping you out throughout
this time
so in the lower panel uh we have uh
dr ajit kamath he has a 25 years plus
experience of
on pre-clinical drug discovery and his
work was primarily at pfizer
which is pfizer r d in usa next we have
dr chakra mesha so he has a background
in drug discovery high throughput
screening biochemistry pharmacology
so for 25 years he's been working with
roche and syntax and
dr ramesha laboratory that conduct
research
uh focused on identification and
characterization of
drug targets drug candidates for
multiple disease targets
so a lot of experience they are working
on several pharma projects
and also drug discovery
pipeline so other than that we have
doctor uday saxena he's a co-founder of
a startup biotech called rainy chain
innovation he has published more than 60
papers and have
a lot of 28 patents for to be specific
so he serves as a review
member for many of the panels and he
will be also he is also a mentor
so he'll be also guiding students uh
there dr rama reddy here is a former
scientist and founder of aragon
pharmaceuticals
and he was one of the scientists and
scene at aragon pharmaceuticals which is
now
uh bought by pfizer san diego so now
dr reddy is working on bioinformatics
chemi informatics and computational
chemistry
and uh one of his uh uh work
at pfizer led to i mean there were
several clinical candidates
with with which he has worked with like
cancer and but one of the fda approved
drug for aids which was
which had his work was veera set
so also we have pranit kakkar
puneethakar is a drug discovery
scientist working as a
uh as uh in accenture india he comes
with an experience of a more than a
decade for about chemi informatics and
computational drug discovery and drug
designing so this will be
one of the opportunities in the in the
upcoming month
to work and able to you know translate
your research and then work on drug
discovery aspect and also learn about
molecules and get uh you know feedback
so
another program that is with the same
collaborators is
machine learning for biomedical research
in this program which will be starting
obviously on 14 june you can see right
here on the slides
on the slide so in this program we will
learn to load
explore visualize and analyze biomedical
data using big data analytical tools
and we'll be using uh coding in r and
python
and here it will be like really a
great experience because we will also be
working
on a neural network machine like deep
learning
nlp computer vision so i'm looking into
the
analysis of images also to looking into
the analysis of text
and then we will also learn about
machine learning for small molecules
and uh learn about convoluted
convolution neural networks
and processing of an analysis of omix
data as well
so we will be also applying it for
variety of data that is out there
for biomedical research so this program
will start on 14th june
and uh people who are joining the
research fellowship
will be able to access some of the
resources from these programs
so the second program is of course the
chemi informatics program which we
kind of which i kind of discussed
earlier but i mean to give you an
introduction i mean give you an
overview it will be about the
introduction of all the chemical
like all of structures chemical
interactions databases
so we'll be learning about virtual
screening hits hit identification
uh qsr docking heat to lead modification
admit profiling all of that
and this program will also have a
workshop
dedicated workshop by stradenger so
uh that would be an additional thing uh
with
all that we will be covering uh so one
should like
leading from the genomics
transcriptomics drug discovery
uh to you know target discovery to to
finding molecules and then to be able to
work on that
so that's kind of a complete uh modern
drug discovery pipeline
that we are envisioning with uh this
summer and we'll also have an
opportunity for students
who would be doing all of this and uh
generate some data and information from
themselves
like projects and then to be able to you
know uh
present that project in a symposium that
will be uh again uh
in august scheduled for august and there
we will have
several of these mentors helping our
students who finish
these projects or are completing these
projects for example
uh genomics in the virtual lab so
genomics in the virtual lab is another
opportunity
uh to work with a world-renowned
scientist and a team of bioinformatician
so in this program we will have
association from multiple partners in
including dr sona vasudevan she's a
professor of biochemistry and molecular
biology
at george georgetown university medical
center washington dc
so she will be also presenting disease
uh
associated projects uh and also helping
the participants to learn
how genomics is used at the interaction
intersections uh intersection of data
science and bioinformatics
so uh again this is another opportunity
to be able to work with
a renowned scientist and a team and that
team
includes a team of experts perhaps
bioclues
is one of our close associates so
together with uh you know pinewood tech
and bioclues we see a common mission
uh to develop a new generation of
computational biologists
across asia so group of
bioinformaticians top scientists and
researchers from bioclues will also be
helping students
and mentor bioinformatics projects on
agriculture neuroscience oncology
immunology
and other topics so all those
opportunities will be available for you
in the summer to work uh with us
and get guidance from experts in the
field
another program that we have is
precision medicine as elia was telling
about
telling you all about the christian
medicine program this will be
sorry this will be also in june and uh
here we will be learning about examples
of chronic and acute infectious diseases
uh uh on political oncolytic viruses
and also uh cancer uh problem with
basic and translational on oncology
research
so this program will also be supported
by
uh by by our counterparts in sri lanka
so
the precision medicine program will be
available through our collaborators and
students in sri lanka to get work with
uh get to work with this translational
team
at nishte so these are some of the
opportunities that are there and
as you are connecting with us and
joining the learn platform and also the
social media networks
we will be sharing these informations to
you via email
and also why all those networks but if
you will be joining the uh
research fellowship program obviously
you'll be getting all those updates and
uh link to the sessions and also
resources that will be
uh for this uh entire summer uh
we have so this summer would be a great
opportunity to work on
and develop something and be really
proud of it because end of uh
at the end of the summer we'll be able
to come up and you know work with
students
to finish projects learn much learn
different aspects
of biological biological data types and
also to apply
machine learning and other important
techniques that are really relevant to
today's
biomedical research and also for
academic or any other research
so that's what i wanted to talk to you
all about and
show you the opportunities uh that are
upcoming
so now i'll just pass it on to or may
pass it to
sunalika to conclude the session and
uh say goodbye uh dr mohit we have a
question that's coming up again that
what is the difference between the three
months fellowship program and the six
months fellowship program
could you please elaborate on that and
explain it to them i thought we can take
it this
question over here to make them
understand in a better way
absolutely yeah i mean uh i have been
working with several students and
yesterday we got a publication coming up
uh
by semi and i think uh i think uh
sonalika if you can share that link uh
with
with students as well so uh our research
projects
uh project is uh is a challenging thing
to do
is the challenging work so the research
projects start from you know
understanding the basic
i mean getting the uh getting to learn
about the basic
understanding of how to uh learn and
apply these technologies such as
genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics on all
those uh
areas so it depends kind of depends on
your research project what are your
interest in
what is your interest in so what what
technologies you will be applying
to your research project so based again
on on based on that and how the research
is progressing how much time you are
able to give
so basically we have this three month
option and six month option
so in three months of option uh if you
are starting from zero
so if you if you are starting if you
don't have a
background and as as many of us have
been elaborating and discussing
that you need to go through some of the
course material that are there so if
you're going through the course material
and then
doing a project it's going to take you
time so
i think for those who would want to go
through
example projects discuss all of that
understand the application
of bioinformatics in different disease
types and then come up with their own
project
to kind of become prepared and then
going for a project that
for those i would like to you know
recommend a six-month
uh six-month uh project uh
to be able to come up with a publication
or to have like those sort of goals
for people who are joining uh for three
months
i mean it depends again on the ability
and uh the time that you are giving to
this uh
this uh initiative or this fellowship so
in that case i think you will have to
give more time to finish the project and
everything in three months from writing
report
to maybe writing a draft to uh doing a
video presentation
so we have had several examples where
people were able to do it in
a very short amount of time for example
three months but
again i mean that is something is which
is variable from person to person
so both of the opportunities are there
and if you if you feel that you have not
been able to complete and you can
obviously
there's an option to extend as well
i hope that clarifies the difference
between those two
sonalika thank you so much dr mohit
uh are there any more questions for us
so take a minute and if you have any
questions please ask in the
chat box so we can
mention briefly about this question on
how much effort how much time do you
actually need to have
to be able to finish a project um
i would say that we've done some surveys
that people have kind of told us about
what
did they need to put in to really
benefit from the program
so that's why this summer is actually a
perfect opportunity to do this because
in the summer typically people do have
the time a research question is a
journey
that you can start but you don't know
how to finish and so you can
see people working on their phds for
years and essentially producing one
research project
you can also see people that work you
know for a couple of weeks and complete
a research project but
it depends on so many different factors
it depends on
how big is your data set how complicated
is your analysis
how challenging is the question itself
is that a completely novel question or
is it a question that somebody already
answered and you're just
refining that answer and maybe finding
some new elements to add to that uh
so i think that you know depending on
whether you're a phd
student you're a master's student
bachelors
even high school students have completed
research projects with us in the past
so that's something that you have to
consider
is your background the project how much
training you've had already
and what we help with is refining that
question
streamlining the process from
identifying the data set to developing
that research
and then presentation as well so that
you can present it
well as as well
now for those of you that are applying
for the scholarships i'm just seeing the
question here
the scholarship process requires you to
submit
an application with your cv and you have
to include references
without references we will not consider
you for a
uh for a free fellowship for sure and
we might provide you with discounts if
you come from a country with low income
but the objective of the scholarship is
to offer you
between 50 and 75 off from the
total price of the program the price of
the program if you compare it to other
training is already
significantly reduced and there are
training programs like this
that cost thousands of us dollars and it
does cost
that money because you gain access to so
much
including the time of the mentors
including the big data analysis tools
all of these resources are obviously not
free but are supported by our partners
that are also excited about
making bioinformatics more accessible
if you apply and you do have the
references and they can recommend you
we will actually schedule a time to meet
with you
and then to discuss what the project
process is so that they clearly
understand what the outcome will be
and we will ask them to actually
participate in the august session
that somalica briefly mentioned and we
will share more information
on that in the coming days where they
will be able to
judge the outcome of the program and
hopefully
we'll understand how that can fit in
with the objectives of
whatever program you're in at your
university so it's going to require some
time before you are confirmed
for receiving that discount now that
um time frame just so that you have it
in mind
is before the beginning of june so the
summer internship
is really for three months the
fellowship is for three months
the objective is over the summer to
complete a research project from
beginning to the very end hopefully with
a poster presentation
a video presentation and a submission to
a journal
it could be just a preprint or it could
be actually finding a journal and trying
to submit it now we don't guarantee that
you will get a publication no one can
guarantee that
because it's highly dependent on the
review process
which in itself sometimes takes years so
uh you know we're not going to promise
you a research publication out of this
but a research project for sure
and we know that our methodology works
well if you follow the steps and you can
put in the time
that's a very high probability that you
will have that outcome
and if you have any other questions
about the scholarship you can email us
before submitting
the application and we would be happy to
chat with you and to
help you out in that process now i see
some people here online that have raised
hands in the past
if you do have a question and you want
to unmute yourself
and ask the question please go ahead
and just raise your hand and we'll be
happy to help you
i did want to also mention that we have
a linkedin
group you can join the linkedin group to
connect with all of us
but also to see some of the mentors that
we have
and see some of the people that are
going to be involved here as well
yes rahul um
yes yes so i would like to
thank uh for this opportunity
and i have one question my question is
uh i had a bioinformatics based project
based on docking
yeah it's mainly based on docking
inhibitor ligand interaction
basically on a relation between
autophagy
and the autophagy crosstalk of autophagy
inflammation
and the how on in reacting with the
different inhibitors
the new disease so like
if i present this project to either you
or any other faculty here can they help
me out with this
and can i do this work in your through
here
yes so mohit dr mohini mazumdar who just
spoke
his expertise in academia and also in
industry is on
docking and chemo informatics so you
would be able to review your project
you do have to be a fellow already for
us to start considering the project
proposal so
in theory that topic is fine but because
we have limited resources
and we cannot look at all the projects
that people would like to work on
that will come as a part of our review
process
in the research fellowship and so the
first part of the research fellowship
is to get the training and identify a
project and so we have a whole process
that you go through
to if you already have an idea that's
fine but you still can refine that to
make it
more interesting and more competitive
from the perspective of these experts
that will be giving you that feedback so
if you want to
get their feedback you need to join the
fellowship and then you you will kind of
go through that process does that
answer your question rahul yes sir
okay i have registered for in the link
already for the fellowship
but my question it's partly right
but the issue here is
mostly i want to work on the docking
area of that
as it's very noble so
that's why actually yeah no that's fine
the topic itself
sounds reasonable so when you do have
experts that have that expertise and
they can provide you with that feedback
of course they would have to learn more
about
your project itself and uh you know then
provide you with that feedback so if you
have already registered
you complete your registration on the
link
fellowship fellowship.omixlogic.com
and so once you're in we will actually
have your account information and we can
start that process
does anyone else have any questions
okay so thank you everyone for joining
again today
uh we'll look forward to interacting
with you the deadline for registration
is the end of this month so if you do
want to join
for the summer a lot of exciting mentors
are going to be joining
so please complete your registration yes
lee
you need to raise your hand for me to
unmute you
let me find you
[Music]
yes so if you want to start in this
summer
please complete your registration with
the payment now so that we can start in
june
uh so melika if you can uh find lee
okay there we go there's lee go ahead
lee can you
uh yeah yeah early here
yeah yeah thank you um so i i'm a
student of uh
bioinformatics in uh germany so we
already studied
a genetic everything already because
it's a bioinformatics
and yeah i'm looking at some kind of a
research program that would combine ai
and immunology do you have any
suggestion
well it all depends on so for example uh
uh anita uh dr anita ganza was sharing
her
uh project uh that involves exactly that
we're looking at similarities between
immune responses
in covent infection and malaria
infection trying to understand the
reduced level of infection reported
infection
in among the african population of
copenhagen clinical cases
and so there for example we use single
cell transcriptomics and
determining how different cell types are
activated with cytokine storm and the
different responses immune responses so
i think there's a lot of
exciting opportunities to ask those
kinds of questions
immunology is challenging because it
combines
a deep understanding of immunology
itself the different cell types the
different responses
but also some fairly complex methods of
separation into different types of cells
and
you know monitoring those responses
across many different time points right
so there's
pseudo time there's all kinds of
clustering and analysis of those
immune responses by pathway activation
so it's a challenging and very exciting
area
we're definitely if you have a project
proposal in mind to work on that in the
next few months i think that would be
excellent
um okay a full author deal
[Music]
please go ahead
hello good evening good evening
i'm afraid today calling from nigeria
please my question is about
um i would like to be um partaking the
fellowship program
but you talked about uh getting um
we have to apply for the scholarship you
know if we can
get maybe a percentage reduction
then we have to get a referees too
so the referees what are the classes who
is supposed to be a referee for you
and the rest yes okay thank you so
reference
right so reference like uh if you're
applying uh
you know we are looking for a faculty
member
i don't know is if you are you know
currently a student
it could be your pi if you're in a lab
if it's a faculty member that can
recommend you that you will essentially
complete
the project right so that's the
objective is to have
people recommend that you complete the
project and once you complete that
project
that it aligns well with the overall
goals of the
studies that you are pursuing so if
you're in a degree program that it
aligns with your degree
if it is something that you're doing as
a part of your phd research that it is
aligned with
a phd objective so that's really the
goal
if you're in nigeria i would highly
recommend that you contact our nigerian
team
you can email them africa
at pine.bio so
maybe adekunle can
share also how to contact him
in the chat box okay thank you
so you can email them there's also a
whatsapp number somewhere in the chat
that i saw
that you could probably contact them but
they're knowledgeable in that process
okay emmanuel i see that you've raised
your hand
thank you
emanuel
maybe maybe okay
all right great so um akash uh
akash did you want to ask a question uh
manually i think you re you lowered your
hand let me see your manual
go ahead and manual
okay good morning um
imano from nigeria i would like to
actually question okay stay in the line
of scholarship
um for now i have it i schedule i won't
be able to start
june i would love to start october
uh people apply for scholarship does it
stick over for november
is it possible um i still enjoy
the same package uh-huh yeah so
um of the program right so we
it's a on a rolling basis right so this
is an independent research
program so you will work on your own
project on your own
pace the only choices we really offer
you are either three months or six
months it's up to you
you think you need more time or you
think you want to do it quickly
you decide the scholarship process takes
a little bit of time
because as i mentioned we first learn
about your background
and where you are in the research
process already
we then reach out to the references so
there are two references that you have
to submit
and then we coordinate a time to speak
with them and with you
so that they can understand what you're
enrolling for
and assure that you can complete the
responsibilities so complete your
research project
if we go through those steps and you
think that the best time for you to
start is in october i would recommend
applying for it
maybe in august because over the summer
there will be a lot of research projects
that we'll be busy with
and if it's only for october then
we can do it by august i would say it's
the time to start
okay okay no i mean i love to start
october
so you say okay i should register all
goes right yeah
yeah is it what you're saying yeah okay
thank you so much
yep okay uh akash let me find you real
quick
uh
yes so firstly i would like to
thank your team you guys are really
doing a very good
work uh you you mentioned uh about your
competitor i i don't find any
your work is pretty uh pretty top notch
i would say
i've gone through some of the courses
that's online i have just two particular
question
one is about the program that you are
having
so this is actually more about the
individual project
that you are allotting and giving
a possibility to researcher or student
like me
to do the project is there a possibility
that i can
apologize for the background noise is
there a way that i can
you know remove the project but just be
more learn about it and because i'm i'm
not confident as to what would be the
project because
that may form in the due course of time
to my
my expectations so is that a possibility
because what i see is that has to be
pre-refined
or reclaimed the second question is
about the ipr policy
so i'm currently doing some work with a
lot of the
different professors around and uh so
and if i share that work and since again
this is those way
this goes as in i'm learning and then so
again how
how that has to be taken care of as well
the ibr part so these are the two
particular questions
thank you okay thank you yeah for your
question
uh mohit i'll let you answer the ipr
policy part i'm not sure
that's probably something specific to
india
but about the different training
programs so again we do
have the research fellowship which was
the topic of today's webinar but we have
many different training programs so the
training programs
are not project based in the sense that
you have to develop a completely
independent project
they are based on prepared projects that
our team has
curated from the public repositories
like the national center for
biotechnology information
the cancer genome atlas malaria gen
and many other repositories so you can
always go
to this link and find these upcoming
programs so i'll just give you an
example
we mentioned here a program on
[Music]
data science so machine learning for
biomedical drug discovery
you can join a similar webinar like
today's
focused on this program by requesting
more information
you can see the overview of the program
and
kind of the schedule of the individual
sessions
you can also see the pricing down here
so all of these programs right here if
you go to the top on the different
programs
are either ongoing right now or they
will be starting very soon
so you can take a look at some of these
programs and pick one
focused on genomics transfer atomic
steroscope 2
infectious diseases drug discovery etc
yes and when you join the research
fellowship you will have access to a lot
of different opportunities to sample
different programs
understand which one you're interested
in and also go through the synchronous
training
and that asynchronous training will be
suggested to you by our mentor team
they will actually speak with you and
try to get to know you
uh sending you some forms that you can
fill out
and i would actually recommend for
everyone if you're just joining
and you're completely new to this we
have a number of different courses that
will help you
get started identify an application that
you're most interested in
but also to let us know about you so i
would recommend going through
this introduction to bioinformatics
course or a course for
absolute beginners called uh sorry bytes
and molecules
so you can actually take a look at this
very introductory course
if you are just getting started you can
go through and kind of understand how
this works
all right great so again thank you
everyone for joining i think
we've had a lot of questions thank you
all the research fellows that joined and
shared your feedback
thank you dr anita gansa for sharing
your perspective on the research that
you're doing
sonalika a great presentation today
and mohit as well we're excited to see
you
and we do not provide any jobs
we will have opportunities for a
research project
with a stipend at the end but that's
only for exceptional students like
supanta and so if you're interested
you first need to complete the research
independent research on your side
and then we will discuss the
opportunities after that again thank you
and we'll see you again soon